>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Roberta I.
Shaffer: I think we'll
go ahead and get started
because under the conditions
of commuting
into this city this morning,
it's really impossible to predict
when people might arrive and
what their voyage will be like.
It's my pleasure to welcome you this
morning to the 265th celebration
of James Madison's birthday.
My name is Roberta Shaffer and I
have the pleasure and privilege
of serving as the Law
Librarian of Congress.
This building that we are in is with
James Madison Memorial Building.
It is the only memorial to
James Madison in Washington,
and I'm going to argue that it
is the most appropriate memorial
possible to James Madison.
And here are my reasons.
First, even though Thomas
Jefferson gets all the credit,
I think James Madison was
himself a huge fan of books,
a bibliophile if I may say.
He had a large collection
at his estate in Montpelier.
And when he died, he
was very concerned
about where his books would go.
So in my view, that qualifies you as
a lover of books and a bibliophile.
It's also appropriate that
a building for the Library
of Congress be named for
Madison because he served
in numerous positions in government
and of course had a huge influence
on the very form of
government that we have enjoyed
for all these many years.
The statue that is in Memorial Hall
on the very first floor as you come
into the building has-- depicts
James Madison holding a book
and it is an encyclopedia, a
French encyclopedia, nonetheless,
but an encyclopedia that
covers all subject matters.
So, he is memorialized
in his Memorial Building
with a block in his marble hand.
But the last reason I
think it's appropriate
that James Madison have a
building that's part of the Library
of Congress footprint
named for him is
because I think he really understood
the idea of America's library.
So anybody who has ever
worked at the Library
of Congress knows two
quotes by heart.
In fact, I think you have to
recite them after one week of work.
And these are two quotes by
Thomas Jefferson, the first,
"I cannot live without books."
And most of us who work here share
that very philosophy and passion.
And the second is that there
is no discipline or book
for which Congress might
not have a need to refer.
And that's a big paraphrase, but
it's something along those lines
that Congress needs
universal knowledge.
But there is a quote by
Madison that I think talks
in a little bit different
way about the need
for America's library
or a national library.
And I'm probably going
to paraphrase it,
and I just wrote it down quickly.
But I'm sure I don't
have it by heart.
But it goes along the lines
of "Knowledge shall forever govern
ignorance, and people who mean
to be their own governors
must arm themselves
with the power of knowledge."
And this quote or something
very close to it is enshrined
at the very entrance
to our building,
on the outside of the building.
And to me, that speaks to
giving the people a library
and not just Congress.
So, that is my argument for why it
is so appropriate for James Madison
to have this building named for him
and why we're so delighted today
that you are joining us to
celebrate what would have been his
265th birthday.
And who knows if he was a man of our
times with all of the biotechnology,
he might very well be celebrating
here with us his 265th birthday.
I am going to just very,
very briefly tell you
about our process for today.
I have no idea what that noise
is, but let's just forget it.
OK. We're going to have a
little bit smaller panel
than we initially anticipated.
Michael Signer, we advised him
not to try to drive this morning
from Charlottesville fearing
that he would hit immense traffic
jams when he hit the beltway.
So, he is not joining us but
please do keep a lookout.
We will reschedule his talk
for sometime later in the year.
He is the author of a new
book "Becoming Madison,
The Extraordinary Origin of the
Least Likely Founding Father".
And he's also the mayor
of Charlottesville.
We do however have
the distinct pleasure
of David Stewart to my extreme left.
And David's recent book
is "Madison's Gift,
Five Partnerships that
Built America".
And he will talk to
us about this sort
of networking skills
of Madison, I believe.
David is the president of the
Washington Independent Review
of Books, a phenomenal
online book review.
And I urge you to consult it if you
haven't and don't frequently, I do.
And he is also a scholar, an author
on a number of other presidents--
other books on Madison, but
also presidential issues.
I think there's a book on
the Lincoln presidency.
And then, to my closer left is Mary
Sarah Bilder, a professor of law
and distinguished scholar at Boston
College in Boston, Massachusetts.
And Mary is particularly a poster
child for the Library of Congress
because not only has she done
work on a research on Madison here
within our extraordinary
collections which Jim Hutson,
the chief of the Manuscript
Division will talk to you
about briefly in a moment.
But Mary also used our
conservation technologies
to uncover some very interesting
forensics about Madison.
And we're hoping she'll
talk to us about that.
Mary is a scholar in her own right.
But I understand that she comes
from a long line of legal scholars.
So without further ado, I'm just
going to say one or two more things
and then ask Jim Hutson to come
up to the podium and talk to us
about the libraries
which collections with--
of Madison and the 23 other
presidential collections perhaps
he'll just mention briefly.
But we're going to have
our program this morning.
And then this afternoon,
you are all invited
to a cake reception in Madison Hall.
You can go to Madison
Hall and have cake
and see the wonderful Madison
inscriptions that are down there.
So, that's just the
very first floor closest
to the Independence Avenue entrance.
And we hope you'll
come and have cake.
In light of the circumstances of
metro today, I would venture to say
that there'll be more
cake for everybody.
And the happy news is that David,
Mary and Jim actually
have more time.
And I think knowing their
incredible scholarship,
they will use that time very
productively for our benefit.
If you would be so kind as to
complete the evaluation form
that was in your program, this
will help us with other programs.
And I will ask you-- Oh yes, in the
unlikely event of a water emergency
or other emergency, library
staff will safely escort you
out of the building.
But for now, if you will
please make sure that any
of the carry-ons you brought
for this journey this morning
are safely tucked either in front
or under your own seat, that your
cellphones are not in airplane mode,
but turned off, and
that your minds are
in their open and upright position.
So without further ado, I bring
to the podium my very esteemed
and honored colleague, Jim Hutson,
chief of the Manuscript Division.
>> James Hutson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thanks, Roberta.
I wonder if Madison still thinks
that knowledge will
govern ignorance.
[ Laughter ]
As you know, he died in a-- I'll
talk just a little bit about our--
the Madison collection we have here.
We also have incidentally a--
in addition to Madison Hall,
have a Montpelier or which we call
a Montpelier Room down the hall here
which is a very nice
venue for symposia.
It was a dining hall at one point.
Have they ceased that now?
Yeah. But it holds about 300 people.
It has a wonderful view
of-- towards the airport.
And-- So, that's also a small
gesture on Madison's behalf.
He died in 1836 of course, and
the family was always needy.
John Payne plays into
this immediate--
that's the stepson who virtually
bankrupted Madison I suppose
with his spending habits.
But Dolley sold some
of the collection
to Congress at 1837 and 1848.
The 1837 sale, I'm going to say
very little more about that,
but that did contain Madison's
notes, which we now have--
is one of our great treasures.
It's-- We have a group of things
here called top treasures among
other, the Gettysburg Address,
Lincoln's Second Inaugural,
the rough draft of the
Declaration of Independence.
All of which are very
carefully preserved in a--
deep in the bowels of
the library, in a safe--
they're-- we hope they're secure.
But the-- No, I mean at one point,
we were thinking of moving them
to Fort Knox actually,
and did not do that.
That was after 9/11.
But they're-- So, they're still
here, Professor Bilder saw those.
We do let people look at
them if they can convince us
that they have a really need.
Generally-- That's true.
Most kind of valuable manuscripts
are on the library if for instance
in the Manuscript Division, if
you walk in there and wanted
to see Madison's papers, we
would ask you or anybody else is
that we film-- you'd have to use
a microfilm, nobody likes that.
And I get a constant stream of
people coming over and say, well,
you know, I can't-- you
know, I can't use this,
couldn't I see the original.
But-- And generally,
we'll let people--
if people are doing handwriting
analysis or looking at inks
and so forth, we'll
let them look at that.
And we will let somebody--
I mean, she's not the first
person who's ever seen this.
And so, we will let people
see some of these treasures.
But they have other-- I mean to put
them on an exhibit, you have to--
there has to be an armed
guard and that kind of thing.
So-- But in any case, the 1837
sale did contain the notes.
And I'll leave that alone and not
talk about the nature of the notes,
which has been a kind of
a subject of [inaudible],
isn't he the first one
who accused Madison
for forging the note so to speak?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Hamilton [inaudible], OK.
But there's a long--
there's a history of this.
Yeah. Yeah.
OK. So, Congress got some papers at
1837 and 1848 and treated these--
and generally, the 19th century
didn't seem not to have much
of an appreciation, at
least custodians were,
the sanctity of what we might call,
you know, important manuscripts.
Congress lent some of the stuff
out to William Cabell Rives,
a biographer, I guess just
sort of handed them over.
I mean, Rives was Madison's first
biographer or first-- that's not--
maybe not true, but
he was well-connected.
So, he got substantial
number of papers.
Eventually, they were returned by
a relative and they're called--
we call those the Rives's--
that's the Rives's section
of the Madison Papers.
But I-- Apparently,
Rives did not turn--
Rives's representatives did not
return everything, something.
So, we have those papers
leaving and some not returning.
And then John Todd Payne of course
who was always broke, and Madison--
he almost bankrupted Madison,
didn't he, supporting the guy.
Well, he sold some of them off.
Really, he sold some of them
off to a man named McGuire,
a lot of them off actually,
something about 2900 of them.
McGuire kept them, at his
death, I believe in 1892,
they were auctioned, some of
them, most of them and bought
by Walter Benjamin, a important
manuscript collector at that point.
He sold them to the
Chicago Historical Society,
and the library bought them back
from the Chicago Historical Society.
In 1905-- So we got those back.
That's-- That-- It was
after, however, in 19--
that the State Department in
the 19th century was the keeper
of government manuscripts,
not the Library of Congress.
The library didn't have room.
You've seen-- Some of you
may have seen some pictures
of the library just
overwhelmed by paper.
But the State Department was the--
that was the National Archives
until 1903 when the government--
I don't know, John
Cole I think is out.
Was a law passed or was it just an
executive order ordering the State
Department to return
whatever archives it had
over to the Library of Congress.
>> Executive--
>> James Hutson: I think
it was an executive order.
So, that-- that's how we got--
that's how the library really got
the-- most of our great manuscript--
Washington, Jefferson and others.
The State Department turned--
Because it didn't have any room
and we just moved into
a large empty building
in 1897, the Jefferson Building.
So, that really was the basis of the
Manuscript Division and the source
of our-- some of our
greatest collections.
So in 1905, the State Department
turned over such Madison Papers
out of its hand, and that
was about 8600 items.
We did, as I say, buy
back those things
and most of them went to McGuire.
That was about 2,900.
And over the years, we've acquired
more by gifts and purchases.
The present time that, we-- In
1961, there was a program, this was,
you know, at the heart
of the Cold War.
The library was directed by
Congress to microfilm all
of the presidential papers
and distribute those
microfilms around the country.
So if we were wiped out here,
there would be microfilm
collections available.
And we microfilmed
Madison Papers of course.
Those microfilm collections
have now all been digit--
all of them have been digitized,
we just actually finished.
Some of the 20th century collections
are huge as you can imagine.
We stopped getting
presidential collections
when the presidential libraries--
we don't compete with them.
So, Calvin Coolidge is
the last person we have.
So, you now-- since they have
been digitized from the microfilm
and then a new edition is
coming that will correct some
of the problems of the microfilm.
So to finish, if you-- the
papers are now available
to the public and-- not
however in transcriptions.
If you want those, there's this
massive project at the University
of Virginia publishing
the Madison Papers,
transcribed in good transcriptions.
Those can-- Those are also on film
now, the so-called Rotunda Project.
And there's, as most-- in many
institutes too, you have to have a--
I mean, you can't-- I don't think
you could probably purchase the
right to see them at
your home computer.
But most large libraries
would have those--
would have that edition
as well online.
So, you could see you would
not be troubled with trying
to puzzle out what Madison wrote.
Although, he had a
good had, a small one.
So, that's what I can tell about our
collection, we're very proud of it.
And, you know, we have 23
presidential collections here
stopping with Coolidge.
We don't have the Adams
family, that's in Massachusetts.
We have film-- microfilms of
those papers in the division.
And we don't have Millard
Fillmore and some other luminaries
of the late 19th century.
But it's the place
to go if you want.
Well, not now since everything
is on film and online,
you don't need to come here.
And that's a problem for us
because we live off statistics
and the reading all
over the library.
So, that's good news,
bad news thing.
And so I don't know if we should
prevent, what should we do, Roberta?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
That is correct.
So with that, I'll turn it
back over to the speakers then.
[ Applause ]
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Mary Sarah Bilder:
Let me put this up here.
I'm delighted to have been invited
to speak on this wonderful panel
in honor of James Madison's
birthday.
I woke up this morning and my
dear friend, Judge Hiller Zobel,
had e-mailed me, Happy
Madison Birthday to you.
So, somewhere in the world,
other people know about it.
I'm very appreciative to the
library for having invited me
and to Roberta Shaffer for
that wonderful introduction
and to [inaudible] for unbelievable
assistance in trying circumstances.
The inability to get here
reminds me a little bit
of the convention itself.
Madison arrived on time
and then was aggravated
by everybody else's delay.
So, he would, more
than other people,
probably appreciate the
difficulties of arriving.
I wish I'd thought for myself that
2016 was Madison's 265th birthday.
Because I realize now, it would have
been better for my book to have come
out this year instead of last fall.
2015 was a odd book
to publish a book
about Madison and the convention.
It was the 228th anniversary
of the constitution.
And luckily, I published
with a university press
that doesn't care about
publicity at all.
And so-- Because it was a
little hard to be like, hey,
it's the 228th anniversary.
But I came to view
this non-anniversary
as peculiarly appropriate for a book
that argues that Madison's notes
as taken in the summer of
1787 were not written for us.
In essence, they were not written
for posterity because Madison,
like the other members of
the Philadelphia Convention,
did not know they were going
to write the Constitution.
And they would have been surprised,
I think, to know that, you know,
you could buy their document
on playing cards, right?
I mean, they would
just be astounded,
like really, playing cards?
Or this is my favorite
tchotchke now when I give talks.
I was down at Montpellier,
and sometimes,
I travel with my James
Madison bubblehead,
but TSA really dislikes it.
It looks like something
strange, heavy material
and a wire in my suitcase.
So, I've stopped traveling
with that.
It slows me down.
But this is wonderful.
You can get this at
Montpellier when you go there.
It's a magic towel.
You know, it becomes a big towel.
The joke is, it reconstitutes
itself.
So, you can go find one of--
you can find one of those.
My book, "Madison's Hand, Revising
the Constitutional Convention",
is a biography of the note.
And the book argues that the notes
do not date in their entirety
to the summer of 1787, but
were revised by Madison
as he changed his understanding
about the convention,
the constitution and his own role.
And it explores the
manuscript as a text
and also has a historical
object, basically, an artifact.
And I'm going to be back at the
beginning of May to give a lecture
in the books and beyond series.
And there, I'm going to focus
specifically on the research,
particularly a lot of the forensic
research that underpins the book.
And so, today, I thought I would
just talk generally about Madison
and the Constitutional Convention.
And I'm going talk about Madison
and the convention and some
of the themes of my book
through four aspects of Madison,
Madison the notetaker,
Madison the politician,
Madison the drafter and
Madison the reviser.
And David and I, while being sad
that Michael was not joining us,
are secretly happy because
there's nothing happier
than speakers being told they
have slightly more time to speak
than they originally thought.
So, we're-- I think we're
going to make good use of that.
But we did realize that I
had written my talk to talk
on the convention, and
Michael was going to handle
who Madison was, and
we're missing that.
So, I'm going take the liberty
of reading four sentences
from my book to set Madison up.
So, this all you need to know
about Madison for anything.
This is actually all I talk about
Madison's early life in my book.
"Born on March 16th, 1751," hence
the day we're celebrating today,
"Madison was the eldest
in a large family.
At 20, he graduated from the College
of New Jersey, now Princeton,
and he stayed on an extra
year for additional studies."
He was of course from Virginia,
and had traveled north to school.
"And afterwards, he
focused on politics.
At 25 years of age, he was elected
to the Virginia Legislature,
three years later, to the
Confederation Congress.
In 1783, Madison was considering
law as a possible profession.
And he eventually decides not to
be a lawyer," and Madison's notes
that he's taken are
also at the library.
And in that sense, I think, David
and I probably love that aspect
of Madison, trained a little bit
in law but no longer practicing.
OK. That's all we need
to know to set
up what I'm going to
talk about Madison.
So, I' m going to talk first
about Madison, the notetaker.
In 1815, Thomas Jefferson wrote
to John Adams about Madison's note
of the Constitutional Convention.
And they were then
not yet published.
And Jefferson remarked, "The
whole of every thing said
and done was taken down with a labor
and exactness beyond comprehension."
And Jefferson wrote that,
"It was the ablest work
of this kind ever yet executed."
And Adams says, I will
unlikely not live to see it.
And that was true,
both he and Jefferson
of course died on July 4th.
Ten years-- 11 years later in 1826.
And to Jefferson, Madison seemed
the consummate, notetaker.
But the reality is
somewhat different.
Madison's most significant
and lasting contribution
to the convention is
perhaps his notes.
And this record of the
convention usually referred
to as Madison's notes are the most
complete and detailed description
of the Constitutional Convention.
An official record of the
convention was compiled
by Secretary William Jackson, the
National Archives holds that record,
and notes also survived
from 10 other delegates.
But Madison's notes are the
only ones that cover every day
of the convention,
beginning on May 14th
and ending on September 17th 1787.
And no other notes are as long.
The manuscripts comprise of
136 and a half sheets of paper,
folded in half, and he wrote on big
sheets, and they fold it in half,
with four pages of writing.
He wrote on the front, opened it,
wrote on the second and third page,
reversed it, wrote on the back.
So, it's over 500 pages
of manuscript.
And no other notes depict the
convention as Madison's notes do,
as a political drama with compelling
characters, lengthy discourses
on political theories,
crushing disappointments
and seeming miraculous successes.
And the notes are, as the
library catalogues them,
properly considered a top
treasure of the American people.
But what kind of notetaker was he?
The notes have often been relied
on as if they'd been taken
by a court reporter or stenographer
for the Congressional record.
But the original notes
were actually an example
of a genre we might call
a legislative diary.
In the 18th century, legislative
proceedings were closed,
much like the deliberations of
judges and justices remain today.
And we'll forgive anybody, who
at 11 o'clock needs to look
at their phone, to find out who the
next Supreme Court justice nominee
is going to be.
What the public had a right to was
the final product, the legislation
and the formal general
procedural motions.
Indeed, although the House of
Representatives would open its doors
in 1789, the Senate
actually remained closed
to the public until 1795.
And without published
accounts of debates,
legislators relied
on private diaries.
So, Madison's notes at the
convention were taken for himself
and likely Thomas Jefferson.
Madison had taken similar
notes when he had served
in the Confederation Congress
and Madison had shared
these with Jefferson.
Jefferson was in Paris since 1784,
he will miss the convention
entirely.
At the convention, Madison's
notes practiced political ideas,
his strategies and the positions
of allies and opponents.
And the original notes
reflected what he cared about
and they omitted what he
did not find interesting.
As past scholars, including
Jim Hutson,
have estimated Madison's
notes contain only about 10%
of what was likely
said at the convention.
But that 10% related
almost entirely to Madison.
Madison's notes were not a
contemporaneous complete account.
Most likely twice a week,
on Wednesdays and Sundays
when he did his other
correspondence,
he wrote up rough notes that he
had taken during the proceedings.
His rough notes were likely filled
with abbreviations he
did not know shorthand.
And the notes began as a fair copy
of these no longer
extant rough notes.
Thus in the notes, the
longest speeches appear usually
in Saturday's notes.
Not necessarily because they
were the most important,
but because a Sundays without
meetings gave Madison time
to decipher his rough notes.
And when Madison wrote about
events that had happened on Monday
or Thursday, he knew what
the convention had gone
on to decide in the succeeding days.
These days therefore were
always written with hindsight.
And so, from the first day, Madison
was revising his understanding.
Now, I love talking about the notes
with law students because they know
from firsthand experience that
one cannot take notes while one
is speaking.
In law schools, we still maintain,
particularly in the first year,
the formal tradition of
spontaneously calling on people,
Ms. Bilder, tell us about the case.
And you now, at that
moment, your mind is blank.
You cannot sit and try and answer
the question and write notes.
When they're called on in class,
they either leave their notes blank
or what they often do is they
compose that section later,
reflecting what they realized
afterwards was the right answer.
And most of my students tell me that
in their notes, if they write them,
they're filled with brilliance of
what they must have said in class.
Madison's own speeches in
the notes are thus troubling
in terms of reliability.
Madison wrote what
he wished he'd said.
Indeed, his famous June 19th speech
supporting the national Virginia
Plan was recorded by a
number of other notetakers.
And in their notes,
it's rather meandering.
But in Madison note--
Madison's notes,
it's a well-organized six-page
disquisition on political theory.
Moreover, in the years
immediately after the convention,
Madison likely replaced several of
the sheets containing his speeches.
His motivation is unknowable,
but it may have been to clarify
and expand arguments that he
made or to delete statements
that he might have
been misunderstood
in terms of later controversies.
So now, let me, second talk
about Madison, the politician.
In famous correspondence,
several years after the convention
with Jefferson, Madison Riley
referred to the naked eye
of the ordinary politician.
We don't always think of
Madison as a politician.
Now, I think, David's
book does a wonderful job
of emphasizing this aspect.
And the original notes reflected
Madison's political aspirations.
In them, he emerges as a
proactive political strategist.
The original notes from June
to July 1787 are fixated
on Madison's almost obsessive desire
to create a powerful
national government
with proportional representation
in both houses.
More than anything,
he wanted the states
to lose their representation
in Congress.
Madison came to the convention
desiring what he called the due
supremacy of the national authority
leaving the states, or as he put it,
local authorities, as far as
they can be subordinately useful.
OK. He wanted to end equality
of suffrage of the states.
He wanted the national
government to have the power
in cases requiring uniformity.
He wanted the national
government to even have a negative,
what we might now call
a veto, over state laws.
He wanted the constitution to be
supreme to state constitutions.
As he put it, he planned to strike
so deeply at the old confederation.
Madison opposed completely and
thoroughly the federal compromised
that Congress now embodies in which
the house represents population
in the Senate-- the state.
At first, Madison thought he
would succeed on June 13th.
The convention prepared a committee
of the whole report in which many
of Madison's hopes were realized.
And in the notes, Madison recorded
this report on its own sheet.
His handwriting is beautiful.
It's carefully spaced.
He left the last page blank.
In the many revisions
of the manuscript,
he never wrote on this blank page.
Other places, he had to even
fill in little scrunchie things,
he left that last page blank.
Why? June 13th ended a
critical phase of the convention
and never again would
Madison's vision and that
of the majority aligned so closely.
Now, those familiar with the
traditional narrative know
what happened.
The small states successfully
fought back.
They worried about
future political dominance
and the other two large states,
Massachusetts and Pennsylvania.
Madison rejected repeated
suggestions that he compromise
and permit one branch of Congress
to reflect the equal
suffrage of the states.
In the notes, he even recorded John
Dickinson warning him privately,
"You see the consequences
of pushing things too far."
Madison wrote down the advice,
and then ignored it completely.
He dismissed it.
It would be a fatal error not just
for Madison, but for the country.
Madison's commitment to ending
state representation in Congress was
so strong that he came
up with a plan
to persuade the three
southern states to join
with the three large states.
He repeatedly hinted at a
sectional division between northern
and southern states over slavery.
And Madison then proposed
a bicameral Congress based
on this division.
One branch would represent
free white inhabitants.
The other would represent all people
free and enslaved African-Americans.
But enslaved African-Americans
of course would not vote.
Madison's plan thus
gave voting power
to states that legalized slavery.
And Virginia, by this calculation,
would have benefited the most,
it held nearly 300,000 people,
enslaved nearly half the enslaved
population in the United States.
Madison's idea was
never formally adopted.
But his insistence on a
sectional division over slavery
and his suggestion that
the slave states needed
to protect their interests in the
national government instigated,
I believe, the dynamic that led
to five constitutional
provisions protecting slavery
in the constitution.
And although after
leaving the convention,
Madison would blame South
Carolina and Georgia
for what has been seen now as an
inevitable compromise over slavery.
Madison was equally at fault.
His willingness to embrace slavery
in the constitution reflected his
personal compromise over slavery.
He believed it to be against the
principles of the revolution,
but he could not imagine a
multiracial American nation.
He freed no one at his death.
Indeed, his will left the
profits from the sale of the notes
of the convention to the
American Colonization Society,
a group dedicated to sending
freed African-Americans back
to Africa specifically Liberia.
Now, on July 14th, I
think fortunately for us,
Madison lost his quest
to prevent the states
from having equal representation
in one branch.
And Madison was mad.
On Monday, he recorded
failed efforts
to resurrect proportional
representation in both branches.
He writes of an early morning
meeting among the large states,
nothing was accomplished.
He complained, "The time was
wasted in vague conversation."
Although in future years,
he actually became reconciled
to American federalism.
Initially, the loss was not
at all palatable to him.
He was so mad.
He went on to do something
he would later regret.
A mid-disagreement over
the executive on July 17th,
a motion was made from Virginia
for an executive on good behavior.
That is an executive who would
serve for life without term limits,
only dismissible through
impeachment.
Madison and the Virginians joined
three other states to vote in favor
of it, lifetime tenure
for the president.
Whether or not you agree with
that, it depends on whether
or not you like the president.
The vote was likely actually
aimed at emphasizing the need
for the executive to have
free agency from the states,
but the vote would haunt
Madison after the convention.
It looked like Madison had voted
for a secret monarchical
national government.
And this sheet in the note is one he
replaces and then repeatedly tries
to explain by adding footnotes
along the side and up the margins,
it's the sheet that's most
marked up in the actual note.
So now, let me talk about
Madison, the drafter.
On July 18th, after this vote,
Madison wrote Jefferson referring
to the drudgery of taking his notes.
On July 18th, Madison was just
depressed beyond all anything.
But ironically, it was his
notes that would save him.
In fact, if Madison had quit
taking notes on July 17th,
we would have only his
account of his failures
and he might have been a permanent
outcast at the convention.
But gradually, Madison emerged from
defeat and failure into a new role.
He became a constructive
participant and was chosen
for the most important committees.
Initially, Madison
was such an outcast
because of his adamant stances
for bicameral representation--
bicameral proportional
representation
that he wasn't even elected to
the first drafting committee,
Randolph was elected instead.
And after the drafting
committee came back,
each member was given
a printed draft.
And unlike everyone else at
the convention, Madison copied
in hand the first draft
over into his notes.
This process of copying gave
him an intimate familiarity
with the structure,
language and substance.
He noticed every word.
He even noticed that the
printer had made an error
in writing Roman numeral sixth above
both the sixth and seventh articles.
So, he knew the draft as
well as anyone who had served
on the committee and
he had no stake in it.
Madison's notes, now
rougher and more erratic,
reflected Madison's fascination
with the drafting process.
He loved drafting.
He had loved it in the
Virginia Legislature.
He loved words and the
struggle to find the right word.
And now in the convention, he turned
out to have a talent for working
out semantic compromises that
sidestep theoretical disputes.
He found himself proposing textual
changes or he was often able
to point to a later
provision in the draft
that resolved a seemingly
intractable issue.
Madison was thoughtful on questions
about which matters belonged
on a constitution and which
would be more appropriately left
to ordinary legislative politics.
And the notes reflected
his growing conviction
that the constitution should
avoid unnecessary specifics.
By the third week of August, Madison
was rehabilitated in the eyes
of the convention, no longer
was he the obsessed proponent
of bicameral proportional
representation
and a somewhat petulant loser.
He had become a valued drafter.
Now, the notes here reflect the
complexity of the drafting process.
The delegates sent
controversial issues late
in the convention to committees.
In fact, there were six
committees between August 18th
and the end of the convention.
The increase in committee
work led the convention
to change its adjournment
time from 4 p.m. to 3 to allow
for all the committee work.
In the last three and a half weeks
of the convention, Madison served
on the three most important
committees, a committee dealing
with slavery, a committee handling
everything that they had postponed
like including everything
about the president as well
as the five-men final
draft committee.
And at this very moment, when
Madison was completely involved
in the production of
the constitution,
his original notes stopped.
August 24th 1787 is the last
page of the original notes.
And although there are notes for
the remaining weeks, I argue,
in the book that they were composed
two years later in the fall of 1789.
This collapse of the
notes is not surprising.
Madison had little time
given his committee work.
In fact, if you chart
out his committee work,
there's literally almost no day
on which he could have
written his rough notes up.
And moreover, he became sick,
something that he was
susceptible to under stress.
And most importantly,
he was too involved
with drafting the constitution
to bother with notes.
And I think he could not keep
distinct decisions made in committee
with those in the convention.
Thus, at the very moment, when
the convention decided many
of the issues we debate today,
certain Congressional powers,
impeachment, the vice
president, the Electoral College,
all the presidential powers and
the grouping and relationships
that converted the 23 final
articles into our seven,
the notes are the most unreliable.
But this collapse of the notes
reflected the contemporary inability
of Madison and all the delegates
to see the final constitution
in the sense that we
mistakenly imagine they could.
The collapse of the notes means
that Madison's great successes
in the final weeks
are invisible to us.
So finally, let me talk
about Madison the reviser.
Two years would pass before
Madison composed the final weeks
of the notes.
And by then, his rough notes were
undoubtedly difficult to decipher.
And moreover, in the intervening
two years; the convention had begun
to acquire a different
set of meanings.
In fact, as a member
of the First Congress,
Madison had repeatedly
confronted the difficulties
of interpreting the constitution.
In addition, he'd champion
the successful amendment
of the constitution
with 12 amendments,
the ratified 10 we know
today as the Bill of Rights.
Significantly, Congress's
decision to add rather
than interweave those
amendments made the constitution
and the conventions work
for the first time begin
to be seen as sacred.
In the fall of 1789, Jefferson
was expected to return from Paris.
And Madison decided
to finish his notes.
He secretly acquired
the official journal
of the convention from
George Washington.
And George Washington's diary that
would have recorded this is missing.
OK. Madison made a copy
of the entire convention
journal, Yale holds that copy.
And then he used this journal
copy to reconstruct the notes.
He interspersed the official record
of the proceedings with remnants
of speeches from whatever remaining
rough notes he had in his memory.
And then, Madison went back over the
first part of his notes and he began
to add in more material from
the journal to alter words
and phrases here and there.
He even substituted three
sheets in early June
to replace earlier unsatisfactory
versions of his speeches.
After Jefferson returned, Madison
continued to revise his notes.
Jefferson became obsessed
that Hamilton
and his allies were secretly devoted
to a more monarchical government.
And this devotion had begun at the
convention, Jefferson believed.
In the early 1790's,
Madison replaced five sheets.
Each containing a speech or
vote capable of being read
as Madison aligned with Hamilton.
Now, you probably wish as he was
given Hamilton is like making
in a 900-dollar tickets, OK.
I haven't seen it.
Madison could not completely
rewrite his speeches
or pretend he had not spoken,
too many members remained alive,
many with notes, but you
could ensure that sentences
in his own handwriting would not
be used as evidence against them.
In comparing other
versions of his speeches,
I speculate that Madison carefully
eliminated his most controversial
conclusion and he also sprinkled
in occasionally Jefferson's new
buzzword, Republican Government.
And during these years, Madison
began to revise the notes
to convert his diary
into a record of debates.
And along the way, he converted
himself into a different Madison.
In the original notes, he's
caddy, grumpy and annoyed.
But by altering a word
here, a phrase there,
he became the moderate
dispassionate observer,
thoughtful intellectual founder,
future statue downstairs,
right, person.
He revised concepts, terms,
narrowed general statements,
added caveats through--
in cross references.
At times, his revisions
border on fussiness.
And after retiring from
the presidency in 1817,
Madison continued to
revise the notes.
By this point, the Madison-- the
manuscript was covered in revisions
in various shades of ink, some
even showing the shake and slant
of his later years often
with small slips attached.
Although he repeatedly flirted
with publication he refrained,
he worried about other accounts.
By 1829, Madison was finally
the only living member left
and he settled on posthumous
publication.
Only after his death were his
notes finally published in 1840.
I believe that Madison
understood his revisions
as repeated efforts
to create a record.
His record of what he saw is
significant in the convention.
And yet, every revision increased
the distance between Madison's notes
and the actual convention.
As a narrative of the convention,
Madison's notes emphasized his
inability and the other delegates
to perceive the extraordinary
document
that the constitution would become.
And equally importantly,
the original notes
of the convention reflect
Madison's inability
to perceive the extraordinary
person that he would become.
I think the Madison of
1787 would be astounded
that over two centuries later,
we'd be celebrating his birthday.
And so, happy birthday
James Madison.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> David O. Stewart:
That was a great talk.
And we are all, those of us
who tell this particular field,
in debt to Mary for the
amazing work she's done
on this treasure of
the American people.
And as I told her before, there
were a few times reading our book,
I had thought to myself,
wish I'd known that.
But I also wanted to thank the
library of course for having us here
to honor Madison's birthday.
I always feel that it takes me a
bit out of the corner of weirdness
that there are other people
honoring his birthday.
And also, to proclaim, maybe not
for the first time, but first time
for me that we have to recognize
that they're-- we are on the edge,
I hope, of a rebirth of
interest in this era.
And I would call the current
age, the Age of Miranda.
Many of you, you know, there's
already been a reference
to the musical Hamilton
created by Lin-Manuel Miranda,
he was at the White House with the
cast on Monday leading programs
for the high school kids.
And I saw it last year, it's an
amazing show, it's wonderful.
And I did what any author would do.
I immediately went home and
mailed them a copy of my book.
And he wrote a lovely response.
He said, thank you so much.
I know I didn't do
justice to Madison,
but I only had so much time.
And I was particularly struck by
this just yesterday when I ran
into a neighbor of mine who
has middle school-aged kids.
I mentioned Miranda would've
been at the White House and all.
She said, "Oh, my kids and
everybody at Tilden Middle School
in Bethesda can't stop
singing his songs.
And it has apparently
swept the young people.
They are all singing Hamilton songs.
And apparently in her house,
they-- she has three kids.
They'll actually say, "OK, you sing
Burr's part, you do Jefferson's,
I'll be Hamilton," which is an
amazing explosion of interest.
I am very used to speaking to
crowds of gray heads and the notion
that there are young people
who are getting interested
in this is very exciting.
OK. I became fascinated with
two facts about James Madison
that led me to want
to write my book.
The first is I really concluded
that he was just so central
to the nation's founding.
He was, in my view, the
second most important figure.
Washington is above everybody.
You can't touch Washington.
You couldn't touch him
then and you can't still.
Without him, I'm not
sure there is a country.
But I do believe Madison is second.
And let me just tick off the
list of his achievements.
He would-- He and Hamilton
were central to the calling
of the Constitutional
Convention in 1787 at a time
when the nation really was drifting
arguably towards more anarchical
or at least a fractured state.
Of course, the writing of the
constitution, we've heard something
of his involvement in
that and his notetaking.
The fight for ratification, he and
Hamilton write the Federalist Papers
which are the best political
writing by any Americans ever.
The battle for ratification itself,
the political fight
he and Hamilton lead.
He is the leading member of the
First Congress, often referred to,
in that first year, as
Washington's prime minister.
He writes the legislation
that creates the government.
He writes the Bill of Rights
and fights for their adoption.
He confounds the first
American political party,
then called the Republican Party.
Now, it's still with us,
called the Democratic Party,
and it's changed a bit.
But it was a remarkable achievement.
He was secretary of state during the
Louisiana Purchase, doubled the size
of the nation, transformed
the nation.
He was our first wartime president.
He led us into the war of 1812.
And I would maintain, and you
can think about this afterwards,
that he was our only
two-term president
who had a better second
term than his first term.
If you think about the
presidents in our lifetime,
the second term can be
tricky, Iran-Contra,
Monica Lewinsky, housing crisis.
Yet, Madison leaves office really
with an incredible swelling
of support and prosperity
around the nation.
So, that's his amazing
list of achievements.
The second fact though is
that he is so often unnoticed.
I found myself telling
my editor that he's sort
of the zelig of the founding.
He's always in the picture, but
nobody is paying attention to him.
And it's an interesting
question, why was that?
There is a flip answer.
He was short, he was skinny,
he had a small voice,
he was losing his hair.
And in rooms filled with
noisy people like John Adams
and Alexander Hamilton or with large
charismatic figures like Washington
and Thomas Jefferson,
Madison was easy to miss.
I think that echoes through the
historical memory, and it is true.
But there's another answer that I
think is a lot more interesting,
which is that he really was
different from most great leaders.
Most great leaders, and you--
if your mind wanders to current
presidential candidates that--
I can't prevent that, they often
have strong streaks of narcissism.
They need to be at the
front of the parade,
preferably on a white
horse with a band playing.
They crave recognition and acclaim.
Madison had none of that.
There's a wonderful moment when he's
at his inaugural ball as president
in 1809, it's the first
inaugural ball ever,
and an on old friend
comes up embraces him
and says, "Isn't this wonderful."
And Madison says, "Well, I'd
really rather be home in bed,"
which was really Madison.
He cared about results,
not applause,
about making the American experiment
and self-government a success
in realizing the promise
of the revolution.
I was struck by a description
by a long-term colleague
that under all circumstances, he
was ever mindful of what was due
from him to others and cautious not
to wound the feelings of anyone.
I think many of our leaders
are very mindful of what is due
from to them, much less the reverse.
I became persuaded also that
many of his great achievements,
really most of them, were the
result of great partnerships.
And it was almost as though he
had taken a modern personality
assessment, one of these things that
determines whether you're an ISPJ
or an introvert or an extrovert,
and had concluded that he was
in fact short, he was
skinny, he has a small voice
and he had zero personal magnetism.
All true. But an honest self
assessment would also have concluded
that he was smarter than
almost everybody he met.
He had a rear capacity
for hard work.
He had good political
judgment and foresight.
And he had a gift and that's the
gift in the title of my book.
A gift for working with others
for checking his ego at the door
and making something happen.
That gave me the lens to
look at his career as a man
who understood the
power of partnership.
I studied particularly
five partnerships
because this is a somewhat
condensed program I'm going
to speed through them.
The fifth one I may linger on
for a minute because it was,
for me, the most interesting.
The first of course was Hamilton
but this was before he could rap.
But he was such a contrast
in character, flashy,
charismatic personality, an
orphan from the West Indies,
comes with nothing,
incredible talent.
He was good at everything,
he tried soldier,
lawyer, statesman, financier.
And he meets this quiet fellow from
Virginia who's a fortunate son.
His father owns 5,000 acres
of land and 100 slaves.
And they connect, this is in
the early 1780's and a Congress
that was not filled with
distinguished people.
And they recognized in each
other, I think, two things.
One was that they both were
smarter than everybody else.
And that they both were committed
to making the United
States a great place
and a great nation in the world.
They collaborated on the calling
of the convention arguably the
most important step that was taken
in creating this new government.
And then, at the convention,
Madison had an up
and down convention as
Marry has described.
Hamilton had a catastrophic
convention.
He actually gave a speech
that lasted for five hours.
That alone is enough
to cause trouble.
But he then, in his speech, argued
in favor of a president for life
and a Senate that would
serve for life.
But he came back at the
end of the convention
and announced he would support the
constitution even though no man's
opinions are more different
from this than mine.
And he's the one who came up with
the idea for the federalist papers
as an advocacy piece to get people
to support the constitution.
Because when it was published,
there was much more opposition than,
I think, they had anticipated.
He tried to recruit
people to help them
with the writing, three
didn't work out.
He ended up finding-- his
fourth choice was James Madison
and a brilliant choice it was.
They ended up producing 190,000
words of extraordinary insight.
Then, they put down
their pens and went off
and led the ratification fights
in their state conventions.
Now, the second alliance
or partnership was
with George Washington.
He was not a pear, nobody
was a pear of Washington,
I'll quote the great Miranda again.
There's a moment in the show
when George the third learns
that Washington is resigning,
which he can't believe anybody
would actually give up power.
He says, "Can you do that?"
And he hears that John Adams
is going to be his successor
and he says, "Compared to
Washington, they all seem small."
And that was the way our society
had to develop our nation.
Madison figured out very fast that
if he wanted to have an impact
on the new nation,
he-- standing close
to Washington was a great idea.
Washington is famously referred
to as the indispensable man
and Madison made himself
the indispensable man
to the indispensable man.
He got legislation
that Washington wanted.
He wrote speeches that
Washington needed.
He famously wrote the inaugural
address that Washington delivers
at the beginning of the government.
And there's a wonderful moment then
when Congress receives this address.
It's short, it's very measured,
only asks for one thing,
the Bill of Rights.
And they think, well, we're
setting presidents here,
we ought to acknowledge the speech.
So, they need to come up with
something to say in response.
So, they asked James
Madison to write it.
And then, Washington
gets their response
and he's a courtly Virginian and
he doesn't want to give offense
so he needs to say
something in replay.
So, asks Madison to write that.
So, the early year of the
government is, in many ways,
James Madison talking to himself.
The third partnership
is with Thomas Jefferson
and that's the one we mostly
think of with Madison.
They were soul mates.
They grow up 30 miles apart.
They-- Jefferson was
eight years older
but they had so much in common.
They were both fortunate
sons with rich fathers.
And I focused on a part of
their relationship which lasted
for 40 years and covered
every subject.
What I focused on was
the achievement, I think,
they would probably
be least proud of,
which is creating America's
first political party.
This was an era when it was stylish
and necessary for a public figure
to insist that he really
didn't believe in parties,
that they were the elements--
that they were the
instruments of self interest.
Small minded people were engaged
in factionalism not great leaders.
But Jefferson and Madison
found themselves
with a big problem
in the early 1790's.
Hamilton and his financial
program were being the adopted.
Washington supported them
and did not support Madison
and Jefferson's view that those
financial programs were dangerous
that they would create a
much more powerful government
than they had intended
or that we should have.
And they needed to oppose it but
they couldn't oppose Washington.
So they began developing what was
originally the republican interest
in Congress.
Around Madison, he--
like minded Congressman
and began to gather around him.
They then reached out to
political leaders in the states
and ultimately recruited
newspaper editors
and they formed the Republican
Party by the election of 1796.
They have an actual party.
In then, in 1800, Jefferson
wins the election.
It's often said that the
true test of a democracy
or a republic is whether you can
have a peaceful transfer of power
between contending parties.
We passed that test in 1800
with that political party.
An externally powerful force
for much of our life as a nation
but certainly, the first 60 years
from 1800 until the Civil War,
it was the dominant
political party in a way
that we really haven't seen since.
The fourth partnership
was with James Monroe.
Monroe was not somebody
you would ask to write any
of the federalist papers.
He was a military figure.
I was a little distressed
to find that many
of his contemporaries
would say of Monroe, "Well,
he's a nice fellow but
he's a little dim."
And it seemed that Madison
and he had a much more
relaxed relationship with--
the correspondence between
Madison and Jefferson is wonderful,
it's rich, they talk
about everything.
You know, that design
of hinges and philosophy
and science and some politics.
With Monroe, the subject is
politics and it just feels he--
Madison doesn't have to work as
hard when he's dealing with Monroe.
An interesting feature
of their relationship was
that they were opponents,
direct opponents twice.
First, in a campaign for
the Congress in 1789,
when the first Congress was
elected, Madison was identified
with the ratification forces.
And the people who opposed
that, principally Patrick Henry
in Virginia wanted to be Madison.
It was going to be the post--
he would be the poster child
of the bad constitution.
So they recruited this handsome
strapping military veteran,
James Monroe to run against him.
And in an era when people stood
for election rather than run
for election, and Madison
hated to campaign,
he really had to campaign
against Monroe.
They went around the district
doing campaign events at churches.
And he did ultimately win
that contest pretty handily.
But then, 20 years
later they fall out.
And I skipped one thing, even
though they opposed each other,
they pick up their friendship
immediately thereafter
without any real trouble.
Twenty years later it
doesn't work that way.
Monroe is in England.
He's asked to negotiate a
treaty with the British.
It's a very tough assignment.
The British and the French are
fighting the Napoleonic Wars,
it's a duel to the death.
They're both praying on our
shipping and on our sailors
and they could care less about
America, we're military weak.
And so, to try to get some
piece, Jefferson asked Monroe
to negotiate this treaty.
Monroe spent three years on it,
sends back a terrible treaty.
He got nothing.
And Madison and Jefferson
on the first day agreed
that they would simply put it in the
files and never speak of it again.
Monroe was mortified and he-- then,
when he comes back to this country
in 1908, he allows his name to be
entered as in an opponent of Madison
in the presidential election.
And I could find no trace of
Madison taking any step to campaign
for the office of president in 1808.
He must have done something.
I mean, he had to talk
to some people.
It just had to happen.
But with Monroe, you can find
some evidence that he was working
with a few people on his campaign.
His campaign was really
not a serious matter.
He only got three electoral votes.
But he was bitter and it was a
measure of how bitter he was.
And for two years, these close
friends for decades did not speak
and did not have any connection.
They did not correspond.
Ultimately, Madison is-- knows
he's going to end up with a war
with Britain, he needs a
strong secretary of state.
He cannot abide the one he has
a fellow named Robert Smith
from Maryland who was an
unfortunate public official.
And it was hard to
get fired by Madison.
But Smith managed too and Madison
at that point reaches out to Monroe.
Recruits him back in to
the family, basically.
Appoints him secretary of state
and Monroe was a key member
of his administration,
served as secretary
of state, secretary of war.
And for two periods, he served
simultaneously as secretary of state
and secretary of war,
which is unparalleled.
No on else has ever done that.
Now, the final partnership of
course is with his wife Dolley.
You know, I'd like to spend
a minute or two more with her
because she's so much fun.
She was originally Dolley Payne.
She came from the Virginia
plantation world
but with one big difference
from Madison's background,
her family was Quaker and
when she was a young teenager,
the Quaker meeting in Virginia
decreed that all good members
of the Quaker meeting
would not own slaves.
So, Mr. Payne freed his slaves and
moved his family to Philadelphia
where he promptly became
a cropper in business.
His wife was forced to convert their
house into a boarding house in order
to keep food on the table.
But Dolley flourished,
she was tall for her time.
She had an hour glass figure, a
mischievous smile, black hair,
creamy complexion, bright blue
eyes, men liked her a lot.
And I always like to point out
that Madison surely was short
and he was loosing his
hair and he was skinny.
But of all the frank founders,
he had the hottest wife.
Dolley had a first husband,
he and one of their sons died
in the yellow fever
epidemic of 1793,
leaving her as a single mother.
Madison somehow became aware of her
and fascinated by her, she was--
she had many suitors not just he.
And you can see her playful
nature and sophistication
in the letter she writes the
day that Senator Aaron Burr is
to bring Madison over to introduce
him, Burr was actually a lodger
in Mrs. Payne's boardinghouse.
And Dolley writes that she's going
to meet the great little Madison.
And it's perfect because he was
little but he also was great.
He was rich.
He was intelligent.
He was kind and he was
a political power house.
You could do a lot worse than James
Madison and she understood it.
Writing about Dolley gave me
a chance to see some sides
of Madison you don't often see.
Let me just mention a couple.
In their first term
in the White House,
Dolley's sister Lucy was widowed and
so she moved into the White House
with her three children and
lived there for three years.
And Madison really enjoyed Lucy
but apparently something he liked
to do was to kiss Dolley in front
of Lucy and turn to Lucy and say,
"Does that make your mouth water?"
It's a little creepy, I'll admit it.
But, you've never thought about
James Madison that way before.
They never had children of their own
but they were not this
semi-sad childless couple
that is sometimes imagined.
They had more than 50 nieces and
nephews who often were with them,
which spend weeks and
months living with them.
James, although as very dull fellow
in a large setting, was quite lively
and entertaining in smaller groups
known to tell great anecdotes.
Dolley was always fun and it
was always fun with a purpose.
They were setting a social
tone for the whole nation.
One of my favorite stories
involves in retirement,
Dolley had grown wider with
the years, James had not.
And she would load him up on her
back and carry him around the house.
And they ran races on front
portico of Montpellier.
They were fun.
But Dolley was in truth of
political partner as well,
she had to be vivacious and
charming and the center of attention
because James couldn't do it.
And during his presidency,
they would have a couple
of social events a week and she
would started wearing white turbans
of velvet or silk and she would
put flowers in the top or feathers
or even a piece of fruit.
And James would come and
great everybody very soberly
and work the whole room and
then go off into a corner
with some gentlemen
and talk business.
Dolley would be in the
middle of the room,
everybody would know who she was.
Everyone would be listening with
one ear to what she was saying.
And she made his career
far more effective.
Indeed, the man who lost
Madison in 1808 wrote
that he had lost to
Mr and Mrs. Madison.
I might have had a better chance
had I faced Mr. Madison alone.
And Dolley, of course,
is often best remembered
for saving the Gilbert Stuart
portrait when the British came
to burn the public
buildings of Washington.
I think, we tend not to appreciate
the importance of that at the time.
America had no kings,
we had no history,
the nation was not
even 30 years old.
What we had was George Washington
and that Stuart portrait
had been made into prints
and those prints hung
in many American homes.
And had we lost the Stuart portrait,
it would have been, in fact,
a great blow to American morale,
at a time when having foreign
troops burn our public buildings
and our national capital was already
a tremendous blow to our morale.
Let me just mention two last things.
Mary talked about this and I'm glad.
It's easy for us to get
lost in sort of wonder
of his times and his achievements.
But I think it is important
for us never to forget
that he was a slave
holder for 85 years.
The question tortured him.
He understood completely the
hypocrisy between what he said
in terms of being committed to
human liberty and the way he lived.
As a young man, he bought land
up in Mohawk Valley of New York
and wrote a friend that he hope
to live there never relying
on the labor of others.
He never did it.
I think it was awfully comfortable
having those hundreds slaves
and Virginia gave him an
amazing political platform.
Jefferson was a neighbor,
Washington was a fellow countryman.
It was the biggest
state in the union.
But then, in his retirement
years, again,
with sort of a nascent
abolition movement,
he became tortured
by this issue more.
He wrote memos to himself about,
which was something he did,
about how he might sell off all the
lands out west and use the money
to buy slaves out of bondage
and ship them somewhere else.
They were all a pipe
dream but it was a measure
of what he really did understand
was unfinished business in his life
and a permanent mark on his legacy.
And I have talked a good bit
about his partnerships of course,
but I'd like to close by
focusing again on Madison himself.
He is often portrayed as
this disembodied intellect.
But I do think his greatest
qualities were his genuineness
and integrity and modesty
and open-heartedness.
That's what all these
different partners found in him.
And I thought that
those qualities shown
through in the way he received
the news of the Treaty of Ghent
that ended the War of 1812.
It's in February of 1815, he's
living in the Octagon House
over on 17th street because of
course, the White House was burned.
And a rumor arrives that a treaty
has been signed with Britain.
A Pennsylvania senator
rushes to the Octagon House
to ask the president if it's true.
Let me just read a couple
of sentence from the book.
"The senator found the house dark,
the president sitting solitary
in his parlor, in perfect
tranquility,
not even a servant in waiting.
The senator asked if
the rumor was true.
Madison bade him sit down.
"I will tell you all I know,"
he said, then confirmed
that he thought there was peace,
but he had no official confirmation.
The senator recalled
with some wonder,
what he called the president's self
command, and greatness of mind.
The world of 1812 had truly
been Mr. Madison's war
as his opponents called it.
It was about principles not gain.
It was fought with a quiet
tenacity often ineptly,
and with endless tolerance
of those who opposed it.
A friend of Madison's
wrote years later,
that the war had been
conducted in perfect keeping
with the character of the president.
And when peace came, Madison
welcomed it a darkened house,
sitting alone with his thoughts."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberta I.
Shaffer: Well, this has been an
extraordinary morning for me.
I have learned so much about Madison
beyond what I knew as a young child
that he was the first one to
think about creating a library
for Congress at the
Continental Congress in 1783.
And then also that of course,
he was the sitting president
when we purchased Jefferson's
books and I always believed--
and John Cole, the library's
phenomenal historian can correct me
for posterity, but I think the
must have had a role in that.
But I've learned so much including
David when the origination
of power couple came
into being in Washington.
So, that was just a fabulous morning
to learn more about Jefferson--
excuse me, about Madison--
>> That always happeneds.
>> Roberta I.
Shaffer: I know.
They're so much alike, they get
confused all the time, in fact,
some people call this
the Jefferson building.
It's just terrific to
learn from both of you
about really Madison much more
the man and his, you know,
positives and some negatives.
And maybe we'll be more
forgiving of our leaders
of today knowing that as well.
We do have a little bit
of time for questions
and we do have a roving microphone.
Your question will be recorded,
the session was recorded
so please be aware of that
as you ask a question.
And just raise your hand and
a microphone will come to you.
This person right here.
>> Let me see.
Dr. Bilder mentioned that in the
notes, Madison had in his notes one
of the significant pages on which
you-- he wrote a lot of footnotes
and a lot of-- all around
the page was an apology
for his position regarding
an autocratic president
who would serve for
an indefinite term.
And then, David Stewart mentioned
that same thing about Hamilton
that in his five-hour
speech proposed this
and it was not well received.
I'm wondering if you could--
I'm curious to understand why--
what was the thinking behind their
belief that this was a good form
of a good aspect of
the government to have,
a president who would serve
without a definite term?
>> Mary Sarah Bilder:
Well, I'll start and then--
and David who wrote but also
in his first book can chip in.
There-- Hamilton gives this great
speech, this long speech in June
and people have different
interpretations about it.
Did he really mean it
or did he not mean it.
I believe it was a strategy,
at that time, the national plan
that had been proposed by the
Virginians was under attack
by the small states who wanted
a very weak-- a weak plan.
And I think my own view on this
is that Hamilton basically agreed
to walk in and give a speech
that suggested that the--
that there could be
a far worse plan.
And Hamilton's plan was
actually never adopted.
He never introduced it formally,
he just spoke and if you look
at the plan that was
recorded by Madison,
Hamilton went out of his
way to make everything
like as extreme as possible.
So, I think in a funny way,
I don't know if people
remember a very fine book
by political scientist
Graham Allison,
that argues that policy
makers inevitably move
to the B position once presented
with an A and C. And so,
I happen to believe that
Hamilton created a C position
under which the national
plan became seen as moderate.
I think that was plausible because
Hamilton was from that world
and he did want strong power.
So, I think that explains
Hamilton's position, I--
you know, there was no
president in the western world
so they were trying to figure out
what a president would look like
and they were really wrestling with
this incredibly difficult notion
of how did you get the president
elected and then allow the president
to be independent of control.
And at that time, they assumed
the president would be elected
by Congress and that the
senate would be elected
by the state legislators.
So, for Madison, the anxiety
is that the president is going
to become a man totally
of the state legislatures.
And so, at that moment he, I think,
votes strategically thinking,
arguably maybe this would
be better but more likely
that it would shock
people into trying
to think how you make the
president more independent.
And it's still a really
difficult question.
So, in some ways, I think
they're both moments
where there's strategic moments.
But David's also written about
particularly the Hamilton part.
>> David O. Stewart: Yeah.
Hamilton may have been
interested in the strategic notion
that it would terrify the
state's rights people.
But I do think it was
what he believed in.
I think he did believe
it was critical
to have a powerful executive,
an independent executive
and both Hamilton and Madison
worried about stability.
It's a point on which
Madison often disagreed
with Jefferson, one of the few.
And Madison cared about stability.
So, my reading of Hamilton's
moment in the convention
and his later behavior
where he basically leaves
because he's being denounced,
many other delegates talked
about what a dopey
idea his speech was.
And his fellow New York
delegates have also left
that he just can't be much
of a contributor anymore.
So, he comes back for couple
weeks later but he's mostly gone
after that-- maybe a
week after the speech.
So, I see it as much more what
Hamilton really would have liked.
For Madison, I think it was a
mistake, he may have been sort
of peeved, as Maria suggested.
It's wonderful in his
notes he says what--
and it's sort of embarrassing,
I shouldn't say wonderful.
He says, "Well Dr.
McClurg recommended it."
Who was a very obscure member of
the Virginia delegation and I wanted
to sort of support Dr. McClurg.
And he makes a big point that
Washington did not support it
in order to protect Washington.
This is in, you know, he's
writing the notes years later.
But I think in that moment,
he goofed, he made a mistake.
And that's much more how
I'm inclined to read it.
>> Roberta I.
Shaffer: Any other questions?
Yes, right here.
>> Well, as you say
that Madison, you know,
they probably at the time didn't
realize how impactful this document
would be but-- and this
may not be a fair question,
but can you speculate, either of you
or both on what Madison would make
of the arguments of
original interpretation
versus the constitution being
a living breathing document?
>> Mary Sarah Bilder: You
know, I think one of the things
that probably interests a lot people
who've worked on this is you--
is at the very moment they finished
the constitution, they already began
to disagree over what it meant.
So, I believe there is no moment
when the constitution
is not contested.
The debates over ratification
were basically different ways
of reading the constitution.
And Madison was fascinated in this.
There's a great debate in the very
beginning of the very first Congress
over the question since
the Senate has
to prove the presidential
appointments,
how do you remove presidential
appointments?
Does the Senate get
involved in that?
Or does the president-- it's
something called the removal debate.
And Madison writes letter
after letter to people.
This is great and wonderful and
the document doesn't say anything
and there's these four positions and
how are we going to figure it out.
And so, I think-- and at the time
in the first Congress some
people argue they ought
to follow what the people
of the convention said.
And actually, most of the people
of the convention say, "No,
don't follow what we said,
let's think this through,"
because the document
is already ambiguous.
So, I think my own view is that
they built a document deliberately
broadly so that it would have
more power than the articles
of confederation which
had written itself
out of existence within
the first decade.
So, that would be my own view.
I don't know what David's
going to say.
>> David O. Stewart: Well,
that's exciting, isn't it?
>> Mary Sarah Bilder: Yes.
I can guess.
>> David O. Stewart: I've never
understood the originalist position
very well as a litigator, I wouldn't
look at the constitutional provision
and if it was clear, I didn't have a
law-- then I didn't have a law suit.
And if it wasn't clear, then I
could go in and argue about it.
And if it's not clear well then,
we don't have an original position.
So, you know, if the case gets to
the Supreme Court it's not clear.
There was a wonderful exchange
in an argument a few years back
over violent video games and Justice
Scalia was hammering some poor
lawyer about, you know, what did
James Madison think of, you know--
and Justice Alito broke in and said,
"Council, what Justice Scalia wants
to know is what was James Madison's
position on violent video games."
The world has changed.
You just can't have
this frozen thing
and we never have as Mary said.
So, it's a puzzle to me.
>> Roberta I.
Shaffer: Seeing no other questions,
I'm going to invite you once again
to our cake reception in Madison
Hall this afternoon at 1 o'clock.
I hope you will come to that.
But more importantly, I
actually hope that everyone
in the room particularly, the people
who work at the Library of Congress,
will be in this building often
and will be very proud to be here.
And for those of you
who do not work here,
I hope you will visit the
library physically or virtually.
We count virtually
also so don't worry
if you come virtually,
it's not hurting us.
And in fact, we are delighted
that technology that, I guess,
Madison did not have the benefit
of, enables us to reach greater
and greater audiences everyday
with more and more materials
and more sophisticated
technology because as I think,
everyone in this room knows,
in addition to Madison
and the other presidents, we have
just the most incredible asset here
that any asset could ever be.
And that is the asset of knowledge.
So please enjoy the rest of the day.
Have an easy journey
wherever it is that you have
to go after this morning.
And we thank you so much for coming
today knowing that it's never easy
in Washington to get around.
But this morning was a
real, real challenge.
Thank you very, very much
and thank our speakers.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.